and
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to another
video about conservation today I'm going
to show you the cleaning and repair of
two specimens first of all we have
this frog look how cute this
frog is it was on display in the
mammal hall here  in the museum in a place
where they were little hidden the funny thing
was that visitors as they
walked through the hall of mammals
can tell what it does there that it is not
a mammal so well when
this wooden base was on display  what it
has was covered by these little
red stones yes so now the
whole base is all like with this
half-pink reddish dust so the idea is
that we are going to clean this frog a little
so that it is in better condition to be
able to study it or perhaps bring it back
in  exhibition what we are
doing then at the beginning is
simply taking out all these pebbles
that we don't want but some of
them are in places that are a bit
complicated  two
then we move them a little
here a little there
and this one is getting better and better for the
poor frog without all these pebbles that
are in the way and do not let us
see what is happening with the bones
because the idea of having  this animal is to be
able to see its bones
so we continue to remove the pebbles a little
and after removing the pebbles what we are
going to do is a little bit with this brush
that I have in my hand
and we are going to remove the bobbin that
we do not like at all
and then there we go removing it
and another technique that we sometimes use to
clean
are the same sponges that I already
showed you in the video that I was
cleaning the horse so make sure you
watch this video because it is
great how
all the people who had a
horse skull in the same series of videos
don't miss it
and there you more or less see how it
turns out of course I'm not going to
finish it here because there's a lot of work
to do but it's a first
approximation of how this
poor frog is doing that had all this
red dust and was a little dirty and was not
at all happy at all happy yes
then another thing that I am going to show you
today besides the cleaning of this frog
is
another specimen that also  I was in the
hall of mammals, which is a small
deer, I have it next to me and
now I am going to show it to you when I finish
getting a little more of this dust,
so this is a first
approximation, obviously it is not like this and there
will be a lot left  cleaner when I
finish working with the frog but
first of all the idea is to remove all this
that was next to the frog that we don't
want to have so well at
least now the bones are not at
risk and we can continue cleaning this
specimen in peace  we are now going
to talk about this little
service as I told you it was also on
display in the hall of mammals to
leave the frog on one side
and what happened to it during  the time it
was on display is that
one of its fingers came off and here you can see that I
collected that finger
there
is the little finger so I collected then
the idea that what we are going to do today is
first we are going to get a little of these
pebbles that are around here because they are
on the road see how the leg moves
if it is loose
we are going to put a little protection
here and we are going to use an adhesive that is an
adhesive called archival
adhesive born conservation adhesive yes and what are we
going  to do is to use it slowly
with this crime
you can see it
we are going to wet the brush
and put the adhesive on
the finger yes
and now
with space very carefully
we are going to glue this finger
and you see
how the deer looks with its little finger
stuck so good  The idea was to
show you a bit of the
conservation work that we do here in the museum
with a bit of cleaning and with a bit of
repair of some specimens, as
I told you, we also have a video of
preventive conservation, no  miss it
and we also have another video about
cleaning and repairing
embalmed animal feathers thank you very much
[Music]